ruptura de diálogo en Ecuador el viernes
la conai la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas anunció que no
continuará las conversaciones con El
Ejecutivo ante una supuesta falta de
interés político para resolver los
problemas del país exigió la dimisión
del presidente Guillermo lasso y pidió a
la asamblea nacional que comience un
juicio político de censura contra el
mandatario Señor Guillermo
renuncia al país y de un paso al costado
frente a las acusaciones que pesan sobre
él y su círculo más cercano por supuesta
estructura de corrupción en las empresas
públicas Pero el sábado el ministro de
gobierno Enrique galón rechazó el
pronunciamiento de la mayor organización
indígena que calificó de actitud
antidemocrática y afirmó que El
Ejecutivo iba a quedarse a la mesa de
negociaciones
este gobierno está ejecutando Los
acuerdos alcanzados con las
organizaciones del movimiento indígena y
le está dando seguimiento hasta hoy ya
se ejecutó o está en proceso de
ejecución un 90% de los acuerdos el
proceso de diálogo entre el movimiento
indígena y El Ejecutivo había arrancado
en junio del año pasado juego de más de
dos semanas de fuertes protestas a nivel
nacional en las negociaciones el
gobierno se comprometió entre otras
cosas a reducir el precio de los
combusti subsidiados pero el viernes la
mayor organización social del país llamó
a sindicatos y otros sectores populares
a apoyar una nueva jornada de
movilizaciones El próximo 8 de marzo